TONY STARK
Yeah, peace! I love peace.
I'd be out of a job with peace.
[Screams]
[Gasps]
[Device beeping]
TONY STARK
Do we know each other?
♪♪
ANCIENT ONE
Time.
Reality.
DOCTOR STRANGE
[Screams]
ANCIENT ONE
It's changeable.
♪♪
YONDU UDONTA
Where you wanna be...
That's the question, isn't it?
ULTRON
Every universe...
...is different.
Each one unique.
THOR
Slow down a little bit.
There's a few people in
the room that don't understand...
Not me, I get it.
DOCTOR STRANGE
Who are you?
PEGGY CARTER
The name's Captain Carter.
DR. ARNIM ZOLA
Scheisse!
THE WATCHER
I am the Watcher.
I observe all that transpires here.
But I do not, cannot,
will not interfere.
ERIK KILLMONGER
I guess I have to freestyle then.
QUEEN RAMONDA
Charge!
SCOTT LANG
Hey!
KREE SOLDIER
We have you outnumbered.
T'CHALLA
A Ravager never flies solo...
I said, never flies solo!
KREE SOLDIER
Uh...  Is that some kind of catchphrase?
[Whistling]
YONDU UDONTA
T'CHALLA
You had me worried for a second.
THE WATCHER
Journey to face the unknown,
and ponder the question...
♪♪